joining us now to reflect on what the uh
what the outcome rather of this trial
means for our country
cbs news contributor ibrahim x kennedy
good morning to you ibram kendi it's
really good to see you
i want to start with how are you feeling
this morning how are you processing this
this is definitely your area
i'm feeling better certainly that i that
i felt
when i woke up yesterday
and i'm thinking that the idea that it's
impossible
to convict a white police officer who
who indeed murdered a black american
could be possible now and but i think we
have a long way to go before it becomes
probable or likely when the evidence
substantiates it
yeah many people are using the term that
this is a turning point
but yet i hear others say wait hold on a
second let's not take a victory lap yet
you agree with that oh without question
and i mean it's still the case that
three people per day were killed at the
hands of law enforcement
during the shogun trial it's still the
case that
that police in the united states kill
more people per capita than any other
wealthy country
in the world and it's still the case
that people today are going to get
pulled over
or engaged by the police and they're
going to fear for their lives even
though they didn't do anything wrong
yeah you tweeted yesterday about
systemic justice
what does that look like ibram what does
that mean what does it look like
sure systemic justice means
that we all are treated equally
before the law no matter our racial
our race our gender our class it means
that
our public safety people
and institutions are literally
places and sites that people can feel
safe can draw safety from and it also
means
that we are consistently thinking about
the roots of crime things like how can
we
sort of ensure that that people are not
committing crimes out of despair people
are not committing crimes because they
don't have
you know this will certainly hold a
place in the minnesota history book so
they were saying on the news here on the
local news
that this is the first time that a white
police officer has been convicted
of murdering a black civilian how do you
want history to remember this moment
those are the sounds of minneapolis
waking up we're all safe go ahead ibram
well what i would love to happen is that
over the next few years
we completely reimagine public safety
we put policies in place that really
demonstrate that the lives of black
it as a turning people and see from 2021
there became this rapid decline in the
number of people
who were killed by the police and in the
number of people who
feared the police
all right ibram kindy we thank you so
much for joining us this morning we
really appreciate it i know this is an
ongoing conversation thank you so much